hi there this is steve and uh
i uh did uh three uh videos on how i use
link for check in response to a request
and then it dawned on me that very few
people are studying
uh czech so i thought i might do it for
french and
maybe i'll try it for spanish and
japanese and
other languages if people are interested
um
the first video i did was where to get
the content
well in french if we begin uh at in our
library we can see that
say at the intermediate level there are
a variety of
of content items available so i'm
dealing with pronunciation
francaise
lots of different things um if we prefer
we can look at uh you know advanced
stuff
you know if we're more advanced we've
still got some
pronunciation things there uh laughs
problem
so uh french audio gazette there's a lot
of different things
now i want to have a look oh and the
other thing i should point out is that
on this library page in all the
languages
we have this import bookmarklet and what
you do with that is you
grab it and you drag it up to your
to your uh whatever it's called toolbar
i'm not going to do it because i've
already done it
and then and i'll demonstrate it later
if you want to read from lamonde or some
other newspaper or anything you can find
online
you just highlight it and it
automatically comes in as a lesson to
link
on our library page you can also search
all right
so i'm not going to spend any more time
on that uh let us look at a
lesson which i set aside which i think
is a very interesting lesson
because it's a conversation between one
of our learners
serge who's in france and another one of
our learners makit who is in
montreal and they deliberately set this
up because it's an
opportunity to hear both a french accent
and a quebecois or canadian accent
so we'll play a little bit of the sound
here
um let's get
okay so it's a very casual uh pleasant
discussion
uh quite a collection that they're
putting together
uh and it's an example of the kind of
content that we have
at link and i'm gonna go back into this
text later on and
and explain to you how i would how i
would use this text how i would study
from it
uh but i did want to show you
um how the um
the bookmarklet works now i happen to
have
the bookmarklet it's kind of off the
screen here already
uh on my computer so i'm going to go to
uh lamone which i have in another
tab here and open up an article in
lamonde
and here we go and it's about muslims in
france
and we grab however much of it we want
and you know highlight it
and then i just click on my bookmarklet
and here we go
and sometimes because we had a problem
that the bookmarklet was recognizing
other characters and putting it into
english instead of french or russian or
whatever
you confirm that it in fact is french
you click
import and this will now open up as a
new lesson
now you can also import here it is we
have the same article
already in ready to go now the other way
you can import
is if you have a source of content where
you have both
audio and text you can go to import
click on import and in my case
i have imported a variety of items here
but you can choose to
open a new collection and the advantage
of this import feature is that you can
use material that is under copyright
because you're not going to share it
if you were creating your own or if you
had uh
content that you had obtained permission
to use to share in our library
then you would share it but most of the
time we're importing things for our own
use
in which case we go to the import
collection we press on collection
because
it's an advantage to have things in a
collection
so that you can easily go from one to
two to three now i'm not going to
continue here but
you would have to continue it you want
to confirm that's in french because you
are in french
and then you would bring it in and you
would uh obviously copy and paste the
text
and then you would copy the link to the
audio file
and you will see that when you import
material you identify the audio file and
all of a sudden you have a lesson ready
to go
if as i say it's not under copyright you
can share it with other members
on the other hand if it is copyrighted
then all you can do with it
is is study it yourself so i think
that's enough
in so far as you know
how to deal with content and in the next
session i will
uh start a com studying a couple of
these lessons and and show you
how i would do that so thank you for
listening
and we're on to the next